vous rappeler ce qu'on disait du
bouclier fiscal de nicolas sarkozy moi
je parlerais plus au delà de confusion
fiscal à de confiscation une confusion
fiscale je trouve vraiment qu'on ne voit
pas de lisibilité dans ce dans ce budget
quel est son véritable équilibre
aujourd'hui avec les sf qui est
l'exemple peut-être le plus totémique su
me permettez l'expression
on se retrouve devant une situation tout
à fait extraordinaire je voudrais
prendre un exemple très concret un
citoyen qui a huit cent mille euros de
biens immobiliers et qui a trois
millions d'euros de biens en actifs
actions placements divers payer avec les
sf 21000 euros d'impôts avec le nouveau
système ne prenne une paire a plus rien
trouvez vous ça normal moi non alors on
peut me dire oui mais ça fera revenir
les exilés fiscaux
il faudrait payer droite et de gauche ce
budget c'est un budget aujourd'hui qui
manifestement serre n'ont pas les riches
mais les très très riches je reprends
l'expression de mon ancien collègue
michel sapin s'est vraiment ceux qui
sont le plus au plus haut niveau de
revenus qui seront concernés et il
ignore manifestement ceux qui ont le
plus besoin de la solidarité nationale
et du jour nous pouvons y revenir sur
différentes alors justement dans ce
budget il ya la suppression pour 80% des
ménages de la taxe d'habitation ce satin
peau qui repose sur des bases des années
70 alors ça veut dire que 20 % des gens
ne la paierons oui et c'est le sacré
pour vous une inégalité de fait entre
les 80 % qui seront exonérés et les
autres la taxe professionnelle est un
impôt idiot
rappelez vous qu'il dit jacques chirac
la taxe d'habitation de l'impôt
profondément injuste non révisés depuis
1966 donc il fallait non pas le
supprimer pour 80% mais pour cent pour
cent de nos courses et plus sacré des
investissements bien sûr et parce que
les 20% qui vont continuer à le payer
vont regarder ceux qui ne payent plus en
10 ans mais moi j'ai le droit à accéder
au crès j'ai droit accès à la cantine
scolaire plus que toi parce que tu ne
payes revient au financement de
décideurs publics de la commune
donc moi je préférerais qu'on supprime
totalement la taxe d'habitation et qu'on
rebaptise un impôt plus juste
si c'est possible si naturel la nouvelle
année un nouvel impôt de recettes
fiscales pour les collectivités
s'affadir ce que mes deux voix si je
l'avais déjà une idée en tête il suffit
si oui de partir sur la réalité des
revenus des gens la taxe d'habitation ne
repose pas sur le revenu et bien partant
sur un impôt local basé sur le revenu
des personnes et alors là tout le monde
sera d'accord
donc aujourd'hui on en crée une usine à
gaz et sans pour autant dire exactement
comment se fera la compensation pour les
communes si on comprend bien au sénat
vous ne voterez pas ce texte tel que en
l'état en tous cas vous ne voterez pas
vous savez au sénat nous avons une
double opposition et l'eau et l'air en
tout cas la majorité l hérault sénat
nous sommes dans l'opposition et nous
serons extrêmement exigeant
ça devient très compliqué mais peut-être
que c'est parce que c'est compliqué
qu'il nous faudra être imaginatif et
faire des propositions